uh the important evidence on the latest
Bank of England monetary policy report
so can I start Governor by inviting you
to introduce yourself uh Andrew Bailey
the governor Bank of England he
upel uh I'm the chief Economist at the
back
an extra member of the bank of MBC
thank you good morning Jonathan Haskell
professor at Imperial College and an
external member of the MPC thank you
thank you all very much for coming in
and talking to us about uh the current
state of play uh inflation is clearly
still over 10 percent in the UK it's
five times your target
food inflation is I think over 16 which
shows why inflation harms the poorest
and those on fixed incomes are the worst
and
for a second round effects that you've
given us evidence on in the past that
particularly you were particularly
Vigilant about seem now to be everywhere
that you look in the economy there are
wage pressures there are strikes there
are there's Services inflation uh there
seems to be a change in household
inflation expectations and now even the
government has said that it just wants
to see inflation halve over the course
of this year which would take it to five
percent or two and a half times your
target so governor do you accept that
the bank has made mistakes in terms of
this tightening cycle but you started
raising rates too late uh too slowly and
you've really let inflation run away in
this country and it will now be harder
and more painful to get inflation back
to Target well I know we've discussed
this before and I would start by saying
that we can't we don't make policy with
the benefit of hindsight I have to start
with that I'm happy you know I'm happy
to comment on if you like the sort of
the history and I think it's important
because we obviously
learn a lot from that but I do just want
to say that we we don't have the
benefits of making policy with hindsight
there have been a number of very big
shocks hitting the economy
over the last three years starting with
covid I think would have been going
going past that I would pick out
now you know a number of very big shocks
that have hit the economy uh the first
one I would pick up and roughly do them
in order of appearing was the supply
chain shock that uh appeared
as the recovery from covid started
that's a global shock
and it was really something to speak for
myself now actually it was really that
shock that you know caused us to use the
term transient or transitory about the
nature of it because at that point in
time we really saw that as a single a
single supply side shock that was part
of the recovery from covert I should say
that if we go back to particularly
somewhere like the summer of 2021 the UK
economy was substantially below the
level of activity that it had been
pre-covered because it is still below
the level of activity pre-covered but at
that point it was substantially below
but the reason that you know use we use
it I use it so I mean we weren't the
only Central Bank using the term Transit
Trail transient was because you know a
single supply side shocked like that on
its own ought to work its way through
the system and what I would say now with
the benefit of having seen how things
evolve is and actually that's that has
that is what has happened with that
shock probably it peaked around the end
of 2021 on most measures and has now
come off quite substantially however
two other very big or two other shocks
have hit us the very big one is Russia
Ukraine
this is the one that is it you know in
census is the dominating shock of the
last year
as I'm no doubt will come on to it it's
also how I thought in a sense that the
moving on from it is also why we expect
inflation to come down rapidly this year
now you know we've discussed before at
these hearings I don't you know I don't
think any of us could have predicted
what was going to happen in Russia
Ukraine until quite near to it actually
happening
but it is a very big shot but it has a
second effect which I'll say you know I
talked about the effect of single Supply
shocks but what we've had is a sequence
of them and there's no air gaps between
them and that of course makes them much
more persistent and much more difficult
to deal with and the sort of if you like
the sort of conventional wisdom that you
can accommodate the first round effects
of a single supply shop you know start
to go out of the window at that point
the third shock is the one that you know
we've discussed a lot before and I you
know really take take to me in a sense
highly relevant to your question which
is then the question of the labor Supply
in the UK
you know as we've observed and as we've
commented on extensively and the
monetary policy report there has been a
decline in participation in the UK now
many countries had a decline in
participation in the sort of initial
covert period
what sort of differentiates the UK is
that it hasn't recovered and and this is
the the Judgment come back to this
question about judgments we had to make
at the time and you know I mean I
remember you saying and you're right on
a number of occasions in the past you
could observe elements of tightening
going on
um and and you know our response to that
in a sense was yeah we don't disagree
our agents were telling us this as well
the challenge we had to deal with was
that
the Thriller scheme was in place at that
time until the end of September 2021
around about a million jobs were on you
know were furloughed right until the end
of the scheme and so the big question
was what was going to be the impact of
earning the following scheme now by the
way I'm not criticizing it I thought I
was going to do like a job but it
created this problem
of judging what the effect at the end of
it being now we thought inflate
unemployment would rise at the end of it
by the way I looked back you know look I
look back and it could take our August
2021 monetary policy report we always
published sort of later on in the in the
reporter comparison of our projections
with those of other forecasters we rush
at the low end of of the assessment of
the rise in unemployment that would
follow from the end of the first game
but of course it didn't happen
and that's the that's the you know that
in many ways I think the you know the
important part of your you know
assessment of where we stand now we've
got a tight labor market very tight
labor markets we've had a fall in
participation and it hasn't recovered
the final thing I'll mention which is
the shot that didn't happen was Omicron
so when we you know when we were
considering the timing of the you know
the of the initial tightening of
monetary policy we were in the right on
the cusp of Omicron and we were being
told it was going to happen
um and that's the one we look we yeah we
said well we think you know its effects
may be less than the earlier economic
effects maybe less than the earlier
covered out race and I think that was a
correct judgment but again it was a it
was a very big judgment we had to make
at the time so
if you don't mind I mean my responses is
we have to make judgments and you know
based on imperfect evidence at the time
we learn a lot of things afterwards and
I agree with you on that
but I do push back on this question
about hindsight judgment
well I'm going to push back on yourself
Governor because I've gone back and uh
you and I have uh discussed this uh
quite regularly uh over the last few
years and uh I want to just pick out
some of the exchanges that the team have
highlighted and I think you probably
will have gone through them and I'm
going to start in may
2021 yeah with your evidence there
because by that time inflation had risen
From Below Target to your target of two
percent and you told us that there are
some very hot spots and very hot areas
of prices and
I just remark on the fact that despite
that the bank decided to keep interest
rates at 0.1 and to carry on with
quantitative easing of our programs can
I just put that into the context of what
I said I don't want to repeat it but but
that's because we were already observing
the global supply chain shop taking
place in there were hot spots
um and there were probably there were
hot spots and domestically because you
know pieces of the economy were
reopening in a you know in sometimes a
rather difficult fashion
um and the question for us was are those
going to be permanent effects or
temporary transient effects that's the
question the Judgment you took at that
point was that it would be yes okay we
then get to September 2021 and now and I
think it's that fourth quarter yes that
I find uh most interesting to look at
respectively
um so by now uh inflation is now over
your target it's at 3.1 percent you're
still
doing the 150 billion of quantitative
easing at that point yes we then get to
uh November 2021
and inflation is now running at 5.1
percent and you're saying I'm now very
uneasy about the inflation situation of
course that is the moment when uh the
committee uh judged that some modest
tightening of monetary policy was likely
to be necessary so didn't actually move
until a bit later on in the Autumn point
where we moved yeah yeah so you're still
at point one at that point
uh and then um well I mean can I just
observe that that's precisely the point
in time that I was just referring to
yeah with these two things that we were
having to assess one was the effect of
the end of the furlitz game and of
course I by the way I said it ended in
the end of September but the data
doesn't come through for another you
know a couple of months and the second
one is Omicron yeah
yeah I mean those are the two things
that yeah we're very much uppermost in
our mind at that point in time I
understand that but you accept that
monetary policy was kept very loose
despite the evidence that you gave us
um is that there is there are there is
risk that it transfers into real
pressure in terms of wage negotiation
yeah the prolonged inflation lead to
higher interests because expectations
all the things
yeah no I
perfectly agree with you on that and but
the reason that I agree with you is
because we were seeking to balance these
various conflicting and you know
countervailing pressures at that time
and to assess what was going on in the
labor market as this million uh jobs on
furlough unwant uh as to how that would
would wind its way through and those are
very difficult judgments
um and we concluded by December that the
right thing to do was to start the Titan
monetary policy but we were still very
uncertain because remember that was that
was just about to go into sort of into
the Omicron wave at that point okay so
let's step forward then to exactly a
year ago uh today by now inflation has
risen to 6.2 percent uh interest rates
are still only at 0.5
and your evidence at that point is to
say I must say that transitory was
becoming a slightly overused and in some
circles over-abused term
um you're Clearly Now pointing to an
upside risk uh second round effects the
risk of real second round effects and
yet
give you the right the rate is still
only 0.5 well the reason that I was made
the point about transitory goes back to
what I said a few a few moments ago uh
earlier on which is that
transitory isn't is a term that in my
view it's easier to apply to a single
Shock by this stage we of course we're
now seeing the unfortunately Russia's
invasion of Ukraine of course was sadly
starting to happen
though the major impact on Energy prices
really came over the summer actually in
terms of the impact so we were seeking
to judge
what would be the impact now on more
than one shock uh and I also would just
make the point that we were the first
major Central Bank to you know to
tighten monetary policy so yeah this was
a this was a problem the challenge that
others were having as well
but on that day the day before Russia in
invaded Ukraine inflation was already
running at six percent of this country
and interest rates were at 0.5 yes and I
wonder whether it is your opinion now
not with the benefit of hindsight
because these are all contemporaneous
observations that the risk to inflation
was always more to the upside than to
the downside given the level of monetary
policy that we had at that time and the
second round effects the risks to those
second round effects becoming embedded
were very high at that moment in time
well I think we were still at that point
because of the nature of the shocks that
we were dealing with and then the
question of whether they had transitory
they would be
that was the question that we were still
frankly wrestling with at that point and
these are judgments we have to make I'm
afraid
um yeah we we changed our view on that
as as we went through the summer really
how can how how can people I I do want
to keep on asking the government
um how can uh people feel confident
though that the bank of England has made
the right judgments at the right time in
this period of time and I know that uh
in terms of public polling
um that there's now you know quite a
high level of dissatisfaction
um with the um track record of the bank
I mean I I I can quite understand the
public polling because our job is to get
inflation back down to targets and I
would expect you know the public to the
public will of course expect us to do
that and we will do it and I would
expect that that will be reflected in
public polling so at this point in time
I would I would of course expect the
public to say what you know it's your
job to get inflation down to Target and
my response is yes it is and we will do
it no actually it's your job not to have
let it get to this kind of level of
second round effect either can I well
I'm sorry not to disagree on this point
but there are a very large there's a
very large body of first round effects
going on at the moment
and one piece of evidence for that we
think is that the fall that we expect to
see in inflation this year
which was set out in the military policy
report is the unwind of what we what
we've done called the base effects from
last year this is a very powerful unwind
now there's a second question which no
doubt would come on to about yeah will
there be persistence
but these base effects of unwinding very
powerfully they're shown they will
unwind more as the year goes on because
of the nature of what happened last year
that my mind indicates that there is a
very big first round effect in here why
I will get onto the second round effects
because uh you know five percent now is
the government's own Target it wants to
halve inflation this year uh a lot of uh
the expectations you've set in terms of
your forecast so for it's getting back
down to that level
um I think what worries this committee
is the Persistence of some of those
second round effects um uh persisting at
five percent but I do want to now yeah
I'll say actually I mean as you've seen
from the report we published our our
projection disappearing indicates that
inflation will probably come down below
five percent by the end of this year
I'll forgive the committee for being
slightly skeptical of those projections
given how often we've seen those
projections turn out to be incorrect
well it's right for you to question us
on those and I accept that because what
I would say is that there are really
sort of two counterbiling forces going
on at the moment there is there are very
powerful uh base effects that are going
to come out that have effectively come
out this year and that and that puts a
very powerful negative trajectory on
inflation unless I mean unless we we
have some event in the world that we do
not know about at the moment
and that's that's really down to end a
lot of that is down to Energy prices
now
we are concerned about persistence
um and we you know that's why we frankly
raised interest rates this time because
you could you could justifiably say to
us if you've got this view of inflation
going forwards and of course we did take
different views on this as you'll know
and if those are the table take
different views on this if you've got
those powerful sort of you know downside
forces why are you raising interest
rates again and the answer for me to
that question is I'm very uncertain
particularly about price setting and
wage setting in this country we have got
the largest upside SKU on it in our
forecast that we've ever had on
inflation
which still actually leaves it coming
down to Target by the way I mean this is
stop otherwise it would the central case
would come below targets
so we do put weight on the on on the on
the persistence risk but there are very
powerful downward forces that share
other things equal
thank you Governor I'm going to turn to
Hugh now and I know sylvana has a point
that she wants to raise and Jonathan as
well
um but you you are very kindly uh sent
the committee a sort of self-assessment
of your time on the committee since
September 2021 and we're publishing that
uh today and I thought what was very
interesting in your uh self-assessment
is that it's slightly different from the
speech and the evidence that you've
given here in Parliament before where
you did uh stress this phrase about with
the benefit of hindsight that we heard
from the governor just now because in
your self-assessment questionnaire I was
intrigued by your paragraph seven
because you admit that in that pivotal
time that we've been talking about the
Autumn 2021 uh decision uh that the bank
waited for the end of furlough to Titan
and yet you point in that paragraph
seven to the fact that your network of
agents at that time
uh before the end of furlough was
pointing to tightness in the labor
market and strength of the ability of
people to negotiate increases in wages
can you tell us a bit more about
um
this assessment you've made of how you
should have paid more attention to that
network of Agents contemporaneously
I think I mean first of all let me say
uh the assessment of which I wrote is
one which is made with the benefit of
hindsight so I am assessing myself and
looking back over the experience I
personally have had since I joined the
committee in September 2021 and I think
what I'm trying to write is actually
very consistent with what the governor
just said namely we were given this
information from the agents at that time
I think that information was published
in the NPR and was part of what was
reported in the minutes and all the
usual vehicles of communication I think
including the discussion that took place
in this committee
um I mean speaking from a personal
self-reflection looking back and I think
consistent with what the governor said
we faced at that time a very specific
and a very uncertain environment in the
labor market associated with the coming
to the end of the furlough scheme so if
you remember as we were unwinding or as
the government's photo scheme was coming
to an end
there had been some uncertainty earlier
in the year before I joined the
committee about when it would come to an
end
that was largely resolved by this point
but
um in September and through that period
we still had roughly three quarters of a
million jobs on Furler and so the
question I think was the tightness that
was being reported from our agency
Network
um
in the labor market associated with
suggestions around recruiting
difficulties and Rising pressures and
prey would that be eased at the moment
that the furlough scheme came to an end
and I mean prima facie at least
potentially you would release quite a
lot of people who were supposedly in the
jobs that were under the fellow scheme
into the labor market so that would have
been a kind of corrective
mechanism to this typist
and with the benefit of hindsight of
course I look back and think how much
weight did I play place on the um
reports we were getting from the
agencies versus how much weight did I
place on the official data which was
reporting there are a lot of jobs still
on furlough and therefore the potential
for this evening I think what I did at
the time was think well we probably need
to see post the end of the furlough
how those close to three quarter of a
million jobs that were furloughed how
that plays out in terms of both the
survey data we see
the reports we get from the agents and
the official data so data on
unemployment data on wage settlements
and so forth and so on and I
particularly put weight on the official
data which didn't come out as the
governor just said towards the end of
November in early December
and so that led to a sort of view this
is a personal view that it was worth
waiting until we saw that data in order
to avoid making a mistake about how
tight the labor market would prove to be
once the furlough scheme ended
so
I think Labor Market official labor
market data is always seen as a lagging
indicator you've got this marvelous
network of agents that were telling you
that the labor market was tight and uh
you know I wonder whether the fact that
you were new to the committee meant that
you didn't sort of speak up with your
concerns uh loudly enough and uh and and
those were contemporaneous concerns that
you had well I'd say too I mean I was
newsletter committee I don't think that
precluded me from speaking out but
others are probably a Better Business
than I am
um and I mean I want to make clear and I
think that was the purpose of this
exercise if I have not misjudged it to
me to give a personal reflection as a
individual independently accountable
member of the NPC in the report I gave
you which you're referring to so just to
emphasize that was a personal view uh I
would like to think looking back that I
contributed to the discussion of the
committee from the perspective I gave
but certainly the discussion in the
committee and I think this is what's
recorded in the minutes and I think was
reported in the equivalent meeting back
in November and then again in February
2021 was a discussion where this was at
the core and and the point I'd emphasize
is I mean looking back
the reports we were getting from the
agents where the labor market is typed
the reports we were also getting from
the age of Market was there is
uncertainty as to how the end of the
um the furlough scheme will play out in
terms of easing there so in other words
it wasn't just those of us on the
committee who were uncertain it was the
agents and perhaps more fundamentally
the the corporate contacts that we were
gathering the information of via the
agents so I think there was a genuine
uncertainty at that point as to what
would be the impact in the late in the
UK labor market of the end of the
furlough scheme again I I would submit
that uh just characterizing this whole
episode is one with with the benefit of
hindsight there was actually
contemporaneous evidence that on balance
you chose to wait to
um to see whether that followed through
into you know genuine wage pressures and
that's where the hindsight comes in yeah
you did have contemporaneous evidence
can I just add one point because you
know I just want a reflection of
conversations that you know I you know I
do a lot of trips around the country
with the agents and recent conversations
I was in Wales three weeks ago and this
conversation came up with a number of
businesses going back just to that point
in time that you rightly referred to
and I'm saying to me what they didn't
expect this plate this goes to the
inactivity story was that that you know
was their labor force actually saying
I've reevaluated you know my life as it
were and I'm not going to come back to
work and you know they they're open and
saying we didn't expect that to happen
that's it that's part of the inactivity
story of course
I'll bring it into
talk about uh what this information
informs us about your future outlook in
a minute uh sylvaner yeah just just to
put the factors into perspective and the
labor market contribution is very small
the dominant shock in 2022 was the war
in Ukraine and increasing
um uh Energy prices and other
Commodities Foods prices and
um and and and that's important to keep
in mind at the 11 peak in inflation last
year eight percentage points of that was
contributed by energy and other Goods
prices which are largely determined in
global global markets these are mostly
tradable components the rest the three
percentage Point came from Services
which is more affected by domestic input
costs like wages and um and obviously
more influenced by monetary policy now
if we just follow those numbers and take
that eight percentage Point contribution
from abroad
than to have inflation at the two
percent Target last year
given that Services represent uh
two-fifths of the CPI basket
would have necessitated inflation in the
services sectors to be minus 15 that is
to meet the two percent Target in 2022
we would have needed a Services
deflation of 15 percent
now in practice of course the split that
I gave you is not precise you can refine
it some good sectors include some
non-tradable components and monetary
policy can affect good sectors inflation
through other channels and conversely
Services inflation uh contains some
energy and food components in them so
this uh but even if you refine my
calculation the conclusion is that you
still need Services inflation running at
deeply negative in deeply negative
territory in order to meet the two
percent Target now as you can imagine
having deflation of 15 in Services
requires a massive recession much bigger
than the great financial crisis with
unemployment at two digit levels this is
at the time in which the economy was
trying to recover from the Kobe shock
and let's not forget that consumption at
the time an investment uh even now
actually they're still well below their
2019 levels so in my view it would have
been incompatible with our remit to have
inflation at Target last year now uh I
mentioned this eight percentage Point
contribution as we go forward to the
next two um two years uh two to three
years that eight percentage Point as
those prices stabilize or even turn
negative as we've been seeing this will
become zero or negative
that means that the level of services
inflation you will need to meet the
target again with a contribution of
Services of roughly two-fifths would be
five percent that's a level of services
inflation we will need in the coming
years to meet the inflation targets so
um if you have if you really want to hit
Target at all times you need to go from
-15 to 5 which is an impossible task for
any Central Bank I mean you cannot
switch unemployment from two digits I
think what we're keen to ask you to do
and we appreciate that if you're going
to get a massive spike in something like
energy then uh that that
will make it difficult to to achieve two
percent on a you know day by day basis
we accept that
um but it is notable that the day before
The Invasion inflation was already
running at six percent and that the base
rate was at half a percent so on that
day yeah well we learn how you know with
hindsight is that those restrictions in
uh in gas supply had started earlier and
that was not known to us but as I said
it was
yeah yeah that's what I'm saying but we
did we didn't I mean we we could see the
the price effect uh which was not um
which is just the beginning of it but we
didn't know that this would be a
sustained strategy by putting
um going forward so I mean you are at
the time could have seen it as a temple
you mentioned Services inflation and uh
in your latest report you say that
Services inflation is at a new high what
I'm trying to press you on today is that
uh the second order effects in terms of
inflation have now become much more
deeply embedded in our economy and will
be that much harder to remove let me
talk about that yeah yeah so as I said I
mean in order to meet the inflation
targets we would need Services inflation
to come down with from the current 6.8
percent to five percent
is that visible it is and this is what
is in our forecast there are three
elements to that first Services
inflation does incorporate uh some
energy and food components some services
are very intensive in the use of those
and in fact if you look at just services
that are not energy intensive inflation
there has been less than five percent
so naturally as Energy prices come down
there will be a direct slowdown in
Services inflation the second component
is wage inflation and we have already
seen a Slowdown in
Pay growth
in the high frequency measures if you
look at one month and one month or three
months on three months this has been
falling since July and then the last one
and this is of course the big one is
monetary policy we have Titan policy
significantly over the past year and
that's going to be
um uh to have a large impact on demand
hence the labor market and this is going
to be the transmission mechanism that
will ultimately bring inflation in fact
it's going below Target in our forecast
well below targets
um and so so those elements should give
you the reassurance that we are more
than on track I accepted some
year-on-year effects that are going to
roll out where I'm somewhat probing you
here is that whether a five percent
level of inflation has not become quite
ingrained and embedded as a second Road
order effect in the UK economy uh
Jonathan yeah thanks very much I'm chair
I I guess I don't want to move the
conversation backwards but I just want
to say two things one is
um I think it's important if we go back
to the issue around the furlough and the
late 21 2021 discussion that we were
just having I think it's important to
understand that Sylvanas just said the
context in which that was the case
you'll have seen chart 3.7 in our report
on page 82 7 gives the level of
investment over that period and the
level of investment was around 10
percentage points below the pre-oma
level in that late uh in that late 21
period in other words the economy was
extremely subdued and if you were to say
uh you know gosh uh you know I want you
to to tighten monetary policy with an
incredibly low level of investment you
know that would have uh that that would
not normally uh be a very good thing to
do that was one thing to do and then the
second thing which also goes back to the
issue there was absolutely a lot of
uncertainty around the furlough but as
Andrew just mentioned and we mustn't
forget that Omicron was a major threat
at that time as well could I just say a
quick word about that because I think
that is a case study in what we know now
as opposed to what we knew then we now
know that the vaccine was robust against
Omicron but we didn't know that then we
took advice from Chris witty you know
the best advice in the land about the
situation known behind as you remember
when Omicron first came out I think it
was in South Africa there was
significant concern that it would indeed
get past the vaccine the vaccine would
be ineffective against it and I remember
asking Chris witty well what happens
then and he told us the facts and the
facts are that the um a vaccine would
have to be re-engineered that would take
three to six months and we would have to
start vaccinating everybody all over
again now again we know now that that
did not come to pass but if you forgive
my just dwelling on it I think it's a
little study about how we didn't know
back then and we had to make policy with
the benefit of what we knew at the time
sorry for that long are you not
concerned now that the second order
inflationary effects have become much
more embedded in the UK economy well I I
am concerned that they are and that's
why I'm voting to raise but the point
I'm trying to make a slightly separate
point which is with the benefit of the
with with the information we had then we
didn't know that at the time so we did
the right policy decision at the time
Anthony thank you chair can I do just
for clarification when I mentioned five
five percent Services inflation that's
enough to meet the Target because
Services is two-fifth of the basket and
the other side of the basket is going to
be exactly I understand that yes yeah
um
I'm looking at the prospect
ation over the cut over the coming year
uh the bank you declared that we've now
turned the corner and your projections
are pretty much downhill uh all the way
I really get a range of views of what
the risk is to that I'm another
um is there a real risk that won't end
up going downhill the whole way uh and
then second question is uh the
government as you touched on earlier the
government has given itself its own
Target for inflation to Harvard by the
end of the year uh do you think there's
any risk to not meeting that because
also your expectation is that it will
make that I'm going to take a range of
views we'll start with uh Johnson and
then uh go right thank you very much is
there any risk to not going downhill the
whole way this year no thanks for the
question uh Anthony well again why don't
we just refer to refer to the reports
into the hearings about the report so on
page 27 we lay out this rather
complicated table so apologies is a
complicated table there's tons of
information in it which I think speaks
to your issue so as you say see our
projection is CPI inflation will go down
from roughly 10 at the moment to around
four at the end of the year of that
um the energy price uh contribution is
going to take about three and three
quarters uh so that's a fall of six and
three quarters the energy price as say
we publish it you know black and white
in the report is going to take three and
three quarters off that we we can have a
reasonable amount of confidence about
that because of the way that the off gem
price cap works
and uh and our current knowledge of what
the what the Futures curve is now of
course as Andrew was just saying were
there to be another significant shock
then that would imperil that but you
know we've got to do do the best repair
again given the information so that we
know so of that fall of six and three
quarters as I say about three and three
quarters is because of energy there are
indirect energy effects of sylvaner was
just mentioning of course energy has a
direct effect because we buy gas and
electricity but then there are indirect
effects because restaurants have got to
consume energy and all that sort of
stuff
and maybe you know 0.25 to that that's
about four percent of the points on that
um so then that takes you from 10 to
roughly about six and so the question is
where are the other two going to come
from and there I think
um we are being ever Vigilant on that
issue that then gets onto the issue
about what's going to happen in the
labor market what's going to happen to
our export prices and so on
um so again without going through all
the various details in the report all
the numbers are there I'll stop quoting
the numbers
um I think I would say that a lot of
that energy effect is kind of locked in
uh again based on our bottling with
Futures curve and we're incredibly
Vigilant about making sure that the rest
of it comes through does that help yeah
no absolutely said sylvana what do you
see as the main risk to inflation coming
down to four percent next year
um
unless there is another big development
that we don't know about and we have a
you know massive energy shock or
something that we're it's not on the
cards then I think the fall in inflation
is pretty much guaranteed and this is
again that mechanical effect that we
were talking about those prices
um that you know went up incredibly uh
High last year are coming down or
stabilizing and that turns that eight
percentage Point contribution to zero
negative and then you can do the
arithmetic of the rest there are other
things that you're particularly worried
about I mean it's the honestly
given the amount of tightening that
we've put in place
of course basically pardon me nothing
else can really knock it off course then
apart from a big external shock not
something that we know at the moment
and that we possibly can know at the
moment
are you um in the in the latest meeting
you wanted interest rates to remain at
3.5 percent
um do you think that uh the rates are at
the wrong level now then or have you
changed your view
how best we can meet the two percent
Target in the medium term
and in line with our remit and and of
course the reason why our remit focus is
on the medium term and why we build
forecasts is because there are lags in
the transmission of monetary policy to
the economy it takes time for changes in
Bank grade to feed through so previous
rate Rises haven't fed through yet we've
seen very little of that feeding through
about one-fifth of that has come through
the rest is still to come and so the
impact of monetary policy combined with
this energy and other commodity prices
and wine should be more than enough to
get us actually not a Target but below
Target in the medium term and this is
why in my view yes
rates are too high right now and that's
that's why I didn't support this the
vote
so Andrew same question I'm apart from a
big another new energy price shot
because we don't know what do you see is
the other risks to inflation getting
down to four percent next year and is
there anyway I mean just have to be
clear because that our Target is two
percent yeah yeah no not your target but
the predicted four percent yeah
um so sylvana and John were saying I
think the base effects are unless as I
say something happens that we just don't
know about I mean that would be
something like some development in
Ukraine that we just don't know about at
the moment which would be tragic
um those base effects that you know are
sort of solidly built in because they're
sort of arithmetic uh in many ways
I think for me and this this was the big
decision we had this time
um you know you can reasonably of course
as Sylvanas described to ask the
question if you've got that forecast why
are you racing interest rates at those
points we spend a lot of time discussing
this very question
for me there is still substantial
remaining uncertainty particularly about
the domestic the domestic side of things
um because we have had this other shock
which is the tightening of the domestic
labor market and particularly the rise
in inactivity
um
now just give a quick summary what with
what we're hearing and seeing at the
moment on that front uh is it is it of
course at the moment that yeah the
numbers remain tight and they're tighter
than we thought they would be at this
point in time and particularly on the
inactivity side
the agents are telling us at the moment
that there are early signs and certainly
I picked this up when I see firms as
well of some signs of loosening
but that will that will come through
more in a decline in vacancies and in a
possible potentially in a decline in
outer's worked it will not necessarily
come free so much in a rise in
unemployment
and the reason for that and firms say
this to me quite consistently is that it
is so hard to recruit people in the
current environment and has been that
they will be reluctant to shed people
and they're more they're more thinking
in terms of reducing hours rather than
heads that's by the way important for
our forecast because our reducing hours
has a different effects
the young people than losing jobs it's a
it's a milder effect and that does feed
through into people's views on savings
and On Demand
final thing I'd say on that is the I
mean the survey evidence that he was
referring to this earlier and and one
case one of the more prominent ones came
out was it yesterday the day before the
so-called Rec survey does and that's a
leading indicator so there's a lag
before those sorts of surveys actually
you know come to pass as it were that is
pointing to and has been pointing for
some months now to a listening uh in the
labor market and to a listening in pay
for my part though uh you know why did I
vote to raise rates we need to see more
evidence uh that this is happening we
have not yet seen evidence of this and
uh you know I am very cautious on that
front well you know as I said I do think
we've turned a corner in terms of
headline inflation yeah it is not only
Fallen it's now under what we thought it
would be in November in the November
report
but we need to see more evidence that
this uh this process will will take
effect
you mentioned that the risk of the tight
labor market
um yeah what are the risks that uh
inflationary pay rises in one sector and
I think in particularly the public
sector because we're obviously in the
middle of the toughest public sector pay
round for a generation at least what are
the risks that if you had inflationary
pay rises in the public sector that
would help fuel uh wider inflation
well of course I mean most of what we
talked about online Market is about the
private sector not the public sector I
should say and that's that's what that's
where the yeah the pay evidence is
coming from there's quite a big wage now
between private set to pay settlements
and public sector-based settlements
I think uh in terms of the debate on uh
public sector pay and its impact on the
economy I will do I mean I'll be careful
what I say here and I'll just say one
thing and only one thing you know in
terms of you think through to the demand
effects it does depend on how how it's
funded
um in terms of whether the government
borrows more or yes in terms of what its
overall effect is um because there is I
know quite a debate about yeah what's
the impact a public set to pay on on the
overall overall demand and the economy
is it like private side to play or is it
not
um
be careful what I say here I I don't
think you can say there's no effect
I really don't think things like that
but I think it does depend what is the
effect well it does depend on how it's
funded frankly
I mean if the government ends up having
to borrow more
look I'm really careful here because I'm
not advocating anything at this point
because this is not territory the bank
of England would of course want to be in
in economics of it I think it depends
whether you raise taxes or whether you
borrow frankly
yeah and it but in terms of the uh
the actual public sector payorize other
concern other concerns that if it is
inflation across the board in the public
sector are the concerns that it will
raise expectations of inflation across
the board and sort of second order
effects
or is it just that funding issue
well I think it very much depends what
form it would take I mean let's also
remember that at the moment all of these
I mean we talk about inflation right all
these pain supplement schools are under
the level of inflation
um but I think you do have to you do
obviously
you have to be forward-looking here
I mean what I would urge is that you
know when you know when when
particularly going forwards because we
think inflation is going to fall very
rapidly but that is taken into into
account
I mean you're right but obviously a lot
of the payoffers at the moment are below
inflation but a lot of the paid demands
are at inflation or above inflation uh
and if they but if they are met those
pay demands then uh
is it just purely how it's funded and
what could be the impact on inflation
well I mean the points I've made made
before and I you know will make a game
on this point is that if
because of the nature of the shocks that
we've been having and because they are
predominantly external shocks as
colleagues have said this is coming
through the terms of trade
if I'm afraid and I'll I'll make very
clear the surprise to price setting as
well as wage setting it's so important
to say that if of course there's a
continual attempt to beat those shocks
then I'm afraid that's the chair's
absolutely right that's where the second
round effects come from now
let's go I mean we've seen you know pay
settlements in particular private sector
are higher than consistent with the
targets
um but not at the level of inflation uh
and the question for us as I said before
is you know are Are We Now beginning to
see evidence of loosening in the market
which will affect those pay settlements
and there is there is evidence to
suggest that but it's my view too soon
to conclude
well the last question on this program
but if if the if the the government did
meet the inflation wage claims for in
across the public sector uh and borrowed
for it because taxes are already at 70
year high what you said there would be
an impact what what would be the fiscal
impact in that case and that would then
have to feed through yeah what would be
the impact on inflation
well it would it would effectively cause
a stimulation for the fiscal of facts
uh and we would have to take that into
account
so yes it would have enough fat if you
do that in terms of potentially higher
interest rates than would otherwise be
the case well I want to be that clear
you know because this is obviously a
sensitive subject
I want to do no more than lay out the
channels that was asking about the
economics
one of the things
this is a very sensitive subject so I
will merely lay out the channels I'm not
going to advocate in any particular
policy here or there
no no I get that it's but it's obviously
that's one of the factors the government
has to think about when it's uh you know
in the middle of these negotiations
yeah can I ask about um that actually
could have come to Q sorry you haven't
had a chance some other other questions
thank you my my sort of initial question
of what do you see as the main risks of
yeah yeah you've got this forecast of
going down to four percent by the end of
the year uh and apart from a some new
developments in the energy markets in
Ukraine uh what do you see as the main
risk to that and do you and do you think
the government is pretty much guaranteed
to meet its own Target of halving
inflation by the end of the year well I
mean I'm on the end so I I A lot has
been yeah so I'll try I'll try not
totally Echo um I mean I think it is in
so I'll try and pick out my key points
so I I just wanted to Echo something the
chair has said right at the beginning
um Andrew picked up and Andrew picked up
on I mean I think it is important to see
inflation is too high and that has
consequences for households and so forth
which is exactly why we are committed to
get inflation back to targets
um and having inflation go to five
percent or stop Rising Etc is not the
same as getting it back to Target our
Target's two percent and we need to get
back not just inflation's there at one
moment in time but on a sustainable
basis through time and that's the focus
of our ambition and our actions and
hopefully what we achieve
in terms of the forecast and as has been
said by others inflation is forecaster
for and is forecast to fall quite
rapidly the reason it's forecast to fall
is the Myriad image of why it Rose last
year so we had the big rises in Energy
prices driven by external developments
which entered into CPI inflation and
those big Rises will now fall out of the
annual calculation in some cases they
will be replaced by still rises just
smaller Rises but nonetheless that will
result in a fall in annual inflation and
that's what we're looking at
um what are the threats to that well I
think it is important to recognize that
if we get big shocks and those big
shocks might be energy pro shocks but
potentially they could be other shocks
too
um that could have an impact on
inflation but the character of shocks is
that they are uncertain and this is you
know just to go back hark back briefly
to what we discussed when I joined the
bank kind of halfway through the process
that we were discussing in response to
the previous set of questions I mean
when I joined the bank I had a briefing
on where we stand I had a briefing on
geopolitical developments and the Russia
Ukraine situation was mentioned but it
wasn't in the top five
right so it really was a shock what
happened I think sylvaner emphasized
that addressing that shock would have
required big um developments in the UK
economy I think it's also important to
keep in mind
that given the lags in Transmission in
order to have that impact you would have
to have known before the shock happened
to avoid the volatility in price
developments and because it was a
genuine shock in the sense we didn't
have the one year to 18 months
pre-warning monetary policy was not
really in a position to prevent the
volatility we've seen and that's why
inflation went up a lot but it's also
why inflation will come down a lot going
to these base effects
um you know very high level I think in
order to address address inflationary
Dynamics in the economy
um and I I would agree that because of
other developments including those in
the labor market we've just been
discussing we have some domestic Dynamic
and inflation we have done quite a lot
to address that
we've raised bank rate by almost 400
basis points we've gone from a situation
where we were doing QE so now we're
doing QT the communication around
monetary policy has changed very much
since I joined the bank in September
2021 so all of those things have had
their influence on Market rates
including Market rates at the sort of
two to three year Horizon that have a
big impact on mortgage rates and that is
a big channel of transmission of
monetary policy into the economy and
that's something I think is we'll return
to I'd imagine this morning
and I very much agree with what Sylvanas
said about this policy in the pipeline
because of what we have done and because
of the lags that I've emphasized there
is still more effect of this policy to
come through into the UK economy and I
think it is important to see that those
transmission lags are famously non long
and variable and crucially I think they
are also not entirely predictable
and so I would caution against the idea
we can fine-tune developments in the UK
economy so you know when we talk about
inflation going to four percent we have
the famous sort of rivers of blood chart
of inflation and that reveals the
uncertainties some of that uncertainty
is associated with the possibility of
further shocks but some is uncertainties
about how what we do transmits into the
economy and there is an irreducibility
of how that works irreducible
uncertainty there I think
and just again to hark back briefly is I
think that does also caution about too
much focus on is it September November
December because the reality is we don't
have that close control of the economy
so to me the sort of message of the
Autumn of 2021 was when I joined the
bank and this was not because I joined
the bank there was an inflection point
in the conduction of monetary policy and
we went from a mode of being supportive
in the face of the pandemic to being a
mode of tightening in face of
inflationary pressures and I think that
that's the big story and the big story
was right
and I think that will contain inflation
on this sustainable basis over the
medium term and that's the important
thing
I think
trying to expect Perfection on a
month-to-month basis is just to expect
too much of monetary policy makers and I
understand
from where you said oops I understand
from where you sit
that you should hold us to a high degree
we are accountable to you and looking to
Perfection from us is not a reasonable
thing for you I can only speak for
myself but I think I can speak to
something separate others of course we
strive for Perfection but we will fall
short
but at the same time I think it's about
getting the big
questions right and I feel very
confident in line with things that
Jonathan has said that we did get the
big questions right at the end of 2021
and into 2022 by titling monetary policy
and then in the face of the energy price
shock acceleration accelerating the the
degree of tightening
so having said all that I mean to me the
challenge now is
we have done a lot there's still more to
come through from what we have done we
have to be prepared to see it through
um and I think you know in terms of
impact on the economy
we will have challenges we'll have
political challenges we'll have economic
challenges but seeing it through is the
key element of where we are
it's crucial to see it through that we
do enough
to address potential upside risks to
inflation so I would agree with various
things have been said but if you ask me
what is the danger to the four percent
or the danger to going to two percent it
is seeing greater persistence
inflationary Dynamics associated with
stronger pricing power on the corporate
side in the UK economy so Supply chains
disruptions and so forth and so on
and or
stronger wage and cost of elements in
the labor market owing to the unexpected
and continued tightness of the labor
market which we've done a lot of work on
we think in line with what Andrew has
said is beginning to change but
nonetheless there are deep structural
issues what's going on in the labor
market that are not fully understood and
we need to understand better so I think
that is where the issue is
I think we need to guard against doing
too much with policy
because there is a danger of over
steering if there are lags in
transmission
um but at least where I stand now the
sort of right stance which is I think
more similar with what Andrew and
Jonathan had said is that I think we
should be watchful to these risks of
Greater persistence that Port points to
me to looking at developments in price
setting behavior in the corporate sector
and waging cross-setting behavior and
tightness in the labor market and how
that feeds them into Services price
inflation as well I think we've been
pretty clear in our Communications
that's where our focus is
um and should we see things there that
cause us to worry and in particular I
think what you can miss in these
discussions is very understandably we
tend to address these questions like
Shock by shock what's the impact of the
labor market tightness what's the impact
of higher energy prices what's the
impact of the supply chain disruptions I
think what we have to do and where the
forecast helps us in our discussions is
take notice of how these things interact
with each other
so it's the combination back at the turn
of 2021 of that period of supply chain
disruption with unexpected tightness in
the labor market that I think led to
Greater persistence than we would have
liked to see and again it's in the the
course of last year it's the combination
of that tightness in the labor market
with the impact of the energy price
shock and looking forward I think if you
ask me to say what's the biggest risk
the biggest risk I think would be that
it's that interaction with a continued
unexpected tightness in the UK labor
market with some external inflationary
shock rather than one or the other in
isolation that I would be most concerned
with can I just ask you the question I
asked Andrew sorry about that you talked
about wage setting there is Chief
Economist of the bank of England what if
the government
did give pay Rises across the public
sector that were close to inflation what
would be the impact on future uh
inflation and interest rates
I think you're asking me to give a
different different answer
no no no I'm just I'm just teasing
myself I'm sure you'll agree with him a
bit more I think I think to give the
answer I want to give to that I'm going
to have to give you a slightly broader
context you're gonna have to be patient
with me right so but I'm probably not to
run time down through this way so again
if we look at what happened last year
what is the big shock to the UK economy
well as other have said the big shock it
was unexpected as I've said is the
rising gas prices and that wasn't just
unexpected it was a massive shock you
know when I joined the bank the gas
price was 75 Pence per therm if you look
in table one B the average pre-covered
is running at about 50 pence per third
at its peak on uh August bank holiday
last year it's 880 Pence per third so it
went up more than 11 times
sorry are you going to answer my
question I am but this is very important
to set the context right so there is
this unexpected massive shock and
because the UK is a net importer of
natural gas and we are quite Reliant
we're all quite reliant on natural gas
for heating and electricity generation
this represents a very significant
adverse terms of trade shock so you know
I've said this in this room before but
simply put the price of what we're
buying from the rest of the world has
gone up a lot relative to the price of
what we're selling for the rest of the
world so for UK residents that employs a
big squeeze on income absolutely right
so the question at hand is who
who's real spending power and it's
income in real terms real spending power
so who is going to take that cost how is
that distributed across public sector
workers across private sector workers
via government trans transition to
future taxpayers rather than current
taxpayers or to people who rely on
profits for their income rather than
people who rely on wages for their
income so I don't think it's for the
bank of England to have a judgment about
these distributional questions we don't
have a mandate
but the point I want to make says that
was all pre-humbled to get to the punch
line which is the answer to your
question so I apologize I did warn you
it was going to take a while but now we
get to the eventually your question the
punchline to the question is is the way
I see it is the more intense
that distributional battle right so
there is a certain size of a pie it's a
smaller pie than people have liked
everybody tries to retain their real
spending ship parts Power by asking for
a bigger share of a smaller pie it's the
irreconcilability of everybody asking
for that bigger share that is what
drives in towards the country right and
so the implication what you're saying is
if you know whether it's wage bargaining
Behavior or Price setting Behavior or
the actions of public sector workers
versus private sector workers these are
all parts of the intensity that what all
we can do and what we should do and will
do is ensure that we respond with
monetary policy to make sure that the
intensity of that distributional
question does not spill over into
inflation
and so if your point is if things we see
or lead to Greater intensity in that
distribution metal as Andrew said that
implies that monetary policy will be
tighter in order to keep aggregate
behaving the economy in line with price
stability
just to be explicit in that and if the
my last question was on if the public
sector wage
Agreements are of inflation or around
inflation that will what you're saying
I'm just trying to unpack what you say
is that would have some impact on future
inflation oh it's potential I mean there
is certainly the potential for that to
happen and if that happens our job is to
ensure it does not lead to inflation by
responding it with title monetary policy
okay I think I've got questions about
the um bonus Capital now to do that or
just stick with the monetary policy
chair for now and and I just uh wondered
uh Hugh if you could quantify for us
that because you were forecasting 13.1
uh inflation Peak at one point and uh
the peak I think was 10.7
um is that different uh the energy price
cap on households and businesses or or
is it something else
um I mean it largely is so if if you
look back I think you're referring to
the August uh report so in the August
report if you remember at that time uh
partly because of the political
situation in the UK we did not have a
fiscal response to the very dramatic
rise in Europe
um and at the time we made the report
which was based on
um we make an assumption uh about how uh
what wholesale gas prices will be based
on market pricing so the the window we
were looking at for the August report
was basically a two-week period towards
the end of July
um
uh in that period uh that would lead and
it's a it was at that point quite a
mechanical calculation because it's
about Futures prices feeding into the
off-term price cap and so forth and that
that off-gen price cap how it applies to
the average uh household how much energy
they spend in their utility bill that is
what enters the CPI inflation
calculation so there's a fairly
mechanical Dynamic that led to that I
mean unfortunately and this is what we
discussed in this room in September was
it's mechanical and obvious to everybody
so during August wholesale gas prices
doubled again
um and lots of investment Banks made the
same calculation and if you remember
there was this discussion of is there
forecast for inflation which are
actually substantially higher than 13
were they legitimate or not but through
this through this mechanism they were
entire but of course once we had uh the
new prime minister we had the energy
price guarantee and so forth and that
shifted from what could have been uh on
the off-gem measure of average household
Energy bill uh you know potentially
approaching six thousand pounds a year
down to about well two and a half
thousand pounds do you think the
difference between the 13.1 and the 10.7
is by and large explained by the energy
price cap yeah I think they're a big
part of it yeah all right Danny thanks
Chad great
um we've got a bunch of questions so
um appreciate
um fairly Snappy answers I mean uh at
your discretion but don't need too much
context
um and in fact this one I'd really
appreciate it some clarity Governor if I
might start with you with a very
straightforward question
you've said it what the report is now
saying that we think that inflation
we've turned the corner on inflation
that's the headline message I think from
the report but at the same time you're
raising rates yes and you're doing so
before the full effect of the last rate
Rises has been properly felt so can you
just explain for the public what the
message you're hoping they should take
about your assessment of inflation at
this time I'm happy to do that because
this was as I said this is a very big
subject of conversation in the round
we've just had
so I do believe that inflation has just
just turned the corner and the reason
for that is that the last two months
we've seen a lower number but it is also
as I said a few moments ago below where
we thought it would be yeah it's a bit
below where we thought it would be in
the November report
second and probably much more
significant is as we've said this you
know very these very strong negative
base effects that we you know what will
other things equal bring it down quite
substantially more so in the second half
the year than the first half of the Year
by the way in terms of the slope that is
but but they will bring it down
however
um as we've discussed quite a bit
already this morning
there is substantial uncertainty uh not
not around the base effects I mean we've
since covered that off I think by saying
it would take something we don't know
about
in a sense counteract those
but just where the labor market is going
and just where price setting is going in
in the economy now the agencies are sort
of telling us they you know they do see
signs now that it is turning
but my view is that we are at a point
where the uncertainty is such
that and the risks are therefore such
and but bear in mind in the
chart that he was referring to the
so-called fan chart we have got the
largest upside risk on inflation uh that
we've ever had in the life of the NPC
which is over 25 years now
and and the reason for that is that uh
there are a number of stories you can
tell that you know create that risk uh
one is it's obviously low Market
pressures
two would be if if Energy prices do not
keep coming down as the Futures curve of
Market suggests that they will and we
did actually put a number in there so
because we used to use a different
approach which was to take the first six
months of Futures code and then just pin
it basically at a constant level if you
impose that onto the forecast we've got
now you add about 0.8 of a percent onto
inflation so you can see those upside
risks but particularly with the labor
market I'm speaking for myself in terms
of my own my own vote in in this last
round I I want to see more evidence that
we really returned a corner but that we
really are going to go go on now and
particularly it's not just what happens
this year in fact it's not primarily
it's that we do sustain it thereafter
okay so to summarize for a for me uh the
your assumption is that uh that
inflation is now falling but in order to
make sure you need to keep the lid on
demand a little longer
uh yes and well yes and that we need to
see where the labor market and price
setting is going to
okay thank you
um it's very difficult communication I
do appreciate you're you're trying to
basically put the foot on the
acceleration the brake almost at the
same time you want to encourage
confidence but also not uh too much as
Librarians in the system
um so it's difficult communication it
reminds me slightly of the Archbishop of
Canterbury trying to have it both ways
uh he's got divine intervention as well
um uh okay so can I uh given the given
the challenge of the communication I'm
going to slightly sort of attack you all
from both sides if I may
um uh on on the infection prediction so
we've discussed this a bit already but
the predictions for services inflation
still is in fact higher than you
thinking it was going to be last time
around so and that is largely driven by
wages I know you've discussed this with
Anthony but just you you famously said
Governor some time ago that you
discourage people from seeking pay Rises
do you feel Vindicated
by that warning and do you want to be
clear I mean that was in the context of
excessive pay Rises that seek to beat
inflation there's huge points about the
cake or the pie as you said we know why
it would be natural to do that but as I
think Anthony interjected a few minutes
ago that unfortunately the nature of
these shocks these terms of trade shots
is that the country is worse off as a
whole and it's that process but no I'm
not I don't want to sound no I'm not
going to say I'm Vindicated
um it is a very difficult situation for
people in this country and for
particularly for those on low incomes
well let me let me
coming up from the from the other side
perhaps then and talk about people uh
who are working hard on low-income
people in the construction sector so
this is a leading indicator as I
understand it often you can see what's
happening in the economy little further
ahead if you look at what's going on in
construction
uh jobs in that sector of afford it I
mean there's increasing vacancies in
construction mortgage demand is very low
we're putting up rates again how much
uh rate Rises how much interest rate
increases do you think the housing
market can bear at what point are you
would you start to worry about the
effect on
on the housing market from these rate
Rises
well we do follow it very very carefully
what I would say is that and
particularly in terms of new fixed rate
mortgages which is a is of course fixed
rate so now the predominant uh mortgage
type in this country
rates have gone up clearly as I think we
were saying earlier and sylvana was
saying it earlier because obviously
we've put rates up actually over the
last
since November and I think since we have
the hearing in November when I did say I
would hope I hoped that mortgage rates
would come down to have
so you know not not untypical about one
percent actually come down and the
reason for that of course is that is
that the police fixed rate mortgages are
priced off the off the interest rate the
price of the swap curve actually
and we have seen since the sort of the
obviously period of period of difficulty
in September and October the curve as a
whole has come down and that's been
reflected through into into mortgage
pricing so that is helpful I think
this will demand is coming down too
well I think yes but can we those are
some those are slightly backward looking
indicators I think again you know the
effects of last Autumn affected also
activity in the housing market because
you may remember a lot of mortgage
products got withdrawn from the markets
they're coming back onto the market now
so we'll see yes okay
uh thank you um Q can I ask you about
the uh the the future and the sort of
scenario we might find ourselves in I
appreciate there's not totally clear
whether we're going to be in recession
or not very much hope not but but some
significant risk of it if we were I mean
recessions usually involve very low
inflation
with even if we hit the targets that
we're hoping for here we're still going
to be at five percent inflation and
potentially in a recession the
combination of that is terrible it does
take us back to the 1970s
yeah if wages are falling as well prices
are rising that is an absolutely
catastrophic for living standards how
much do you
worry about I'm sure you worry a lot but
to what extent do you foresee a sort of
stagflationary or inflationary recession
so of course we're very concerned about
that
I I hesitate because I know you've asked
me short answers but I just want to put
in context I mean what we can do with
monetary policy
is essentially steer spending in the
economy demanding the economy including
through the channel you mentioned
through the housing market but also
other channels
and we want to steer demand and spending
in the economy such that we don't
generate too much demand relative to the
productive potential of the economy to
generate either more inflation or more
more persistence in inflation but
equally you know there are risks on the
other side if we slow spending down too
much by overt raising interest rates and
so forth then to weak demand relative to
the production potential of the economy
will obviously lead to downward
pressures and prices and ultimately
disinflationary forces that push us
below Target so to meet the inflation
Target sustainably what we're trying to
do is sort of map given the inflation
rate our steering of demand given the
production potential of the economy so I
do think it's important to see and of
course this edition of the monetary
policy report contains a big section
looking at the supply side of the UK
economy it is important to see that the
supply side of the UK economy in our
forecast is weak and that is a
constraint on our ability to let demand
run now to a first approximation I think
to say this is black and white I think
we've taken it too far but to a first
approximation monetary policy does not
have that much effect on the supply side
of the economy and we can talk and maybe
you want to talk about why why we take
the view that supply side of the economy
remains very weak and I think that's
important to put this notion of you know
recession and so forth in context so we
have a very shallow recession by the
historical standards of recessions it's
still a recession in our forecast
meaning on the definition that's
typically used a technical recession of
at least two quarters of negative growth
but we are kind of bubbling around zero
right so in fact the fourth quarter
which we thought would be a negative
number may turn out to be a zero or
positive number and then the second half
of last year may not be a technical
recession once we're bobbling around the
zero sort of level for exactly the
reasons we talked about earlier uh in
given the uncertainties we Face
including the uncertainties about how
policy transmits
um we may see weak Positive Growth we
may see recessions we may see negative
growth so the point is I would I would a
little bit get away from focusing on
recessions but I think we will see a
relatively long period of wheat growth
and the fundamental driver of that is
weakness on the supply side do we do
want to come on to this Plus in a bit if
you don't mind but I mean that might be
true that the recession will be weaker
over overall and seeing from the bird's
eye perspective but actually for
particular sectors of the population
it's going to be very acute Perhaps
Perhaps in fact that's a difference
between recessions historically that
it'll be far worse for some people that
it wouldn't have formally and I think
I've mentioned particular people in
working in construction but you know if
we're talking about wage deflation in a
in in some areas and these price Rises
it's going to be absolutely catastrophic
for a good I mean I think the NIS scr uh
saying this week they're expecting a
course of households to be unable to
cover food and energy
so I certainly don't want to push back
against the cost of this environment it
goes very much to what our chair said in
her opening I think the sentence almost
is I mean inflation has been too high it
may have been driven by external sources
and we're trying to correct it
um but this terms of trade shock has
very big implications and very
challenging implications for a set of
businesses in some sectors rather than
others in some parts of the country
others and sets of households
particularly those towards the bottom
end of the income distribution who spend
more on energy and food so we are very
aware of that I think it's also
important though to recognize that
monetary policy as sort of we've been
discussing is potentially a very
powerful tool to steer aggregate
behavior in the economy but it's also a
very blunt tool and it's just not well
designed to try and have impacts on one
sector or the other and we don't have a
mandate to do that as the MPC of course
we need to monitor that because how our
policy he transmits into the aggregate
is importantly affected by these
distributional effects so we do look at
cross-sectional cross-regional
cross-income distribution impact of our
policies very closely and that's
something we monitor but I think we have
to be cautious about taking
responsibility for something that
frankly we don't have the instruments to
address I appreciate your your very
powerful very blood levers at your
disposal okay thank you very much uh you
Professor tenreo can I can I come to you
uh you know the leading Dove on the
committee so I understand it on on
interest rates um
would you I mean is it possible to ask
you to tell us now what your advice will
be in three months time but at the
moment do you expect to be calling for a
cut in rate and seeing as he didn't
support the raise that we've just seen
when it comes to the next meeting and I
suppose a fair way of asking that is
what will you be looking for
for the advice that if if we were to
expect you were to see you calling for a
cut what would you be looking for in
advance to that and how would you can
what would you expect your colleagues to
be convinced by that would make them
support you in a in a rate cut well I
think I made my points clear that I
think
um policy is already too tight to meet
the Target
in our forecast we have our model
projections for inflation for well below
the target
the meme projection mean inflation also
falls below the target so that means
that the risk to the downside of that
two percent is higher in in those
projections and than the risk to the
upside
um
as I you know again as I said in uh in
um before
um how can we loosen policy one is
directly through cutting rates or
through an inversion in in the curve and
that can happen on its own even without
our actions
um but uh definitely I I you know where
things stand right now I would see
myself
considering a cut I don't want to talk
about a particular meeting because
meeting to meeting doesn't make much of
a difference but the overall stance of
policy right now is uh is losing my view
there are of course as the governor said
upside risks Energy prices can go up but
also as we saw they can go down they're
still much higher than they were
pre-covered
um so there's always that possibility to
do in this round we made a judgment uh
to push up demand and hence inflation
and uh there are also risks to that
um on the downside
um so yeah I have a more balanced view
of the risks at at this stage certainly
around hitting the two percent Target in
the middle term
well thank you I mean I'm going to come
on in a moment to energy cost so that's
okay but um Professor Haskell can I can
I
put the professor 10 raise point to you
if inflation
Falls uh very fast you'll end up below
Target and then you'll have to be having
to uh to to unwind these these right Ray
Rises very fast what what danger do you
foresee if that were to happen are you
worried about having to raise to cut
rates very fast and what what the effect
of that might be yeah thanks
um can I just step back for a moment if
you think about I know you wanted Chris
that's right if you'll forgive me I mean
we've talked a lot
um about uncertainty and so you might
say well what do we do in the face of
uncertainty did we just sort of throw up
our hands and just say it's all too
difficult in my opinion we should not do
that we should do two things at least
one is we should guard very
um uh vigilantly against really bad
outcomes and one really bad outcome
would be a lot of inflationary momentum
in the economy as we've just discussed
the other bad outcome to your question
would be if we undershot the the target
very severely so that's kind of rule
number one rule number two which I think
follows from that is
because of these risks and these
uncertainties we should be super
Vigilant on the signals that we are
getting so as they come along so we can
learn something about the risks
and and therefore better inform our
judgment and the reason I forgive me if
I sort of say all of that is what then
am I doing I'm very worried about
um excessive momentum uh building up for
inflation and therefore I want to guard
against that number one and number two
is
I am putting a bit less weight than I
would otherwise do on the medium term
forecast and I'm looking much more at
the shorter term indicators to which you
might have a watch short-term indicators
and in speeches I've tried to go through
a number of number of those the ratio of
vacancies to unemployment for example is
is I think an important somewhat leading
indicator because putting out of agency
means a firm is indicating in the future
expectations of high demand so I'd be
looking at that
um the redundancy numbers uh again
because many companies have to notify
the government if they intend to make
redundancies under certain circumstances
big amounts of redundancies those are I
think are kind of an interesting almost
accidental kind of leading indicator and
those are very low at the moment the Vu
ratio is very high and more broadly the
indices of inactivity which the governor
has talked about before so all that is
to say
um I am super worried about going under
the target but as I say given the
uncertainties at the moment I'd rather
put weight I'd rather put a little bit
less weight on that medium term forecast
and look for those shorter run
indicators I I hope that's helpful yeah
I'm going to very briefly make one of
the points that we will of course if we
get this outcome of of inflation falling
rapidly we do have to stabilize
inflation at the Target to sort of
emphasize that point because we could
see it go under Target just as we've
seen it go over Target because base
Effects by definition don't recur in the
same way
so that will have to be of course a
critical Focus for us okay
thank you if I move on to energy of
course now brilliant okay next topic oh
very related
um uh so I mean when you came before
certainly it was in November uh governor
and I'll see the impossible question
about how you could have such confidence
that inflation was going to fall when it
was all in Mr Putin's hands it remains
in Putin's hands you know to to a
significant degree and I think you said
in the media last week that as long as
Russia continues this barbaric War
there's always the possibility that
energy prices could go up again yes
um can you just tell us
precisely how you've fractured that risk
into your work I mean it's an impossible
question to answer but it doesn't appear
this war is going to end imminently uh
and there is always the chance of
further
decisions or events choking off Supply
even further how have you factor that
into your well
um this comes back of course what a
number of us have said in the course of
this discussion that you know of course
we can't deal with something that's
totally unpredictable in that sense
we've had to come to that what we have
done I'll just make two points actually
first thing I'd go about something I
said a few minutes ago and is in the
report which is we have done the
you know we've conditioned the forecast
on what we call the full the full
Futures curve either full the full
duration of the Futures curve
now that's a change of methodology
actually from what we were doing in the
past but partly because actually if we
the old macup as I said was we used the
first six months of Futures curve then
we took we took a constant price
thereafter the problem we've run into
was it lasts yeah yeah was it
particularly when going back to the
summer we would have had a very strange
pattern to energy price inflation if
we'd done that actually because of the
but not least because of the way the
sports scheme worked not a criticism of
it
but as I said we have done the what if
the staff did the what if we actually
had the other not the full Futures curve
I they don't keep coming down but they
yeah they they stick it in the way we
used to do it and as I said earlier yeah
staff estimate that would add about 0.8
to inflation now you know that that's
that's that's part of our consideration
in the upside risk we don't build the
upside risk up bottom up we do it rather
top down but then we have stories that
sit underneath it and that's part of it
okay
um can I just make one other point I I
just wanted to make a point that came
out of something here was saying it's
relevant to the energy point
and it's relevant to this point about
low-income households
it's important to know because you gave
the price of 50p a firm as the sort of
pretty stable price pre or the Ukrainian
uh thing starting
this big downshift in in Energy prices
inflation does not take the level of
household Energy prices back to that
level
and of course for the cost of living
that's that you know that's relevant
yeah okay so I just want to wait no no
point taking it I I want to come back
some of your points but Professor do you
want to come in yeah if forgive me just
add a little bit to what Andrew said
being an economics professor of course
I've got to talk about supply and demand
so you'll have seen in the report we
look at the demand for energy and see
whether that has changed uh and would
that affect the Outlook and in chart
2.14 there is somewhat of an indication
that people's demand for energy might
have gone down that's one thing if I may
the second thing if I may is as you'll
know what's crucial in the energy Market
is that in the um is that we build up
very high inventories of gas which we
then run down uh uh later you know to
come into the winter so we monitor those
inventories very closely as well to help
us give a forward-looking picture about
what I understood
I mean they are storage levels that are
up at 80 percent or so in the middle of
the winter so this is a very high level
to start
yeah they're right at the top of the
2017-22 range and more generally I mean
there is a substitution to an
alternative suppliers and sources of
energy which has also ease the pressure
um and could be a source of downside
risk as well of course okay well but we
we applaud demand reduction in energy so
that is uh I mean to be said I mean that
has been huge in Continental Europe in
this country I think there is more to be
done
um great well let's we should we should
think about policies on that I think
wearing three-piece suits is a very
helpful way to produce demonstration I
encourage it for all members of the
committee
um uh so so
um the governor you talked about the
Futures uh Market which isn't in a sense
that seems to be the sort of the God of
this uh
of this bit of policy making when we had
the ABR and we said to them how what are
you basing your predictions on it I
think now we asked the chancellor and he
said the ABR says that the president's
coming down we said to the ob why is
inflation coming down he said because
the Futures Energy Futures the market
says it is they're very very bullish
about reductions in energy costs why do
you think that is what and what I mean
the ball isn't ending anytime soon is
there more energy LNG going to kind of
come out of nowhere why do you think the
Futures Market is so confident
or of course Energy prices first of all
I mean since we came I think since we
had the hearing in November
um wholesale gas prices have come down a
lot it's 50
um I mean I have you know again we have
to sort of you know be clear on the
limits of our knowledge that's not
something we predicted when we were here
in November I think looking forwards I
would say it's a it you know there's a
balance of factors uh in the market and
I think some of them point one way and
some the other way frankly I think you
know Europe has built up its capacity to
receive
particularly liquefied natural gas from
other parts of the world
and that has helped particularly with
what Sylvan and Jonathan were talking
about the storage position that has
helped a lot I I think I think my
assessment would be I don't think
currently there's a large increase in
global investment in more gas extraction
and oil extraction
um so that has obviously will have an
effect in terms of available Supply
I mean it's a very interesting question
obviously about how the Chinese economy
is going to recover and come out of the
covet restrictions and what that will do
to the China's demand for uh for energy
because China's obviously a major
a major importer and of course the the
third factor is
um is Russia uh obviously yeah
parts of the world that are implementing
sanctions have reduced their uh
dependence on Russian supplies uh the
question is you know there are other
parts of the world don't put it that way
yes
um Professor I want to come to you but
can I just ask you in your question to
answer this as well which is to uh to
say I mean it
if we are going to have persistently
high energy costs and they might not be
as high as now but still I think it's
fair to say we're going to have high
energy prices for some time does that
automatically mean persistently High
interest rates in your view
um
let me answer the reason I wanted to
come is was on the bullish point if I
may so just if I can say in chart 2.3 we
do indeed show what you might would
imagine be a very bullish diagram which
is that Futures Energy prices which I
think you're referring to do dive right
down but they dive right down to a level
the axis of the chart starts in January
2022 and I think as Hugh said earlier on
there was of course a big run up in gas
prices in advance to the war
um so although that chart looks like
Energy prices are going to drop back
down to where they were they're still
well above well not made about levels
I'm sorry yes yes indeed Andrew yes
they're still very well above you know
what they were um before that so I
wouldn't if I may I wouldn't be too
bullish on the basis of that chart if
you sort of see what it is okay well
indeed yes yes overall we keep being
optimistic about a full from a very high
rate on all these things back down to a
rate which is not still not comfortable
um do you think so yeah first of all the
other Professor do you still do you
think that hi those high prices are
going to just lead automatically to high
rates as a feature
um no not necessarily um look it depends
how the economy adjusts this is a high
level of prices which is we've discussed
is very painful for people and and I
don't want to minimize that but as far
as inflation is concerned it's perfectly
consistent to have a high level of
prices and it'd be consistent with
falling inflation with constant
inflation um so not necessarily no thank
you yeah that's precisely a point that
was going to make there's a distinction
between the levels and if you know the
change and and here we even if we remain
with very high levels of energy prices
um the contribution they make to
inflation if they stay at those High
elevated high levels is zero I mean as
as long as they don't keep increasing so
that's the distinction now we are still
poorer the country is poorer and I think
that's that's important consideration
too when when we look at other countries
that that are net exporters of energy
and actually this has been a big big
boost to their terms of trade and we see
that reflected in the differences across
countries in real incomes and real
consumption in our case consumption is
still way below 2019 levels if you look
at the US for example which is a net
exporter of energy consumption has been
running above their pre-covery Trends so
you know it's a Divergent picture much
more different so
um
that's very helpful thank you I'm going
to close the chair how are we doing for
time I've got more questions but I'm
conscious of others want to get in and
we want to move on to other topics yeah
what do you think I think I think I'm
going because I know Anthony
um wanted to ask a few things on the
labor market uh and then I'll come back
we'll just bring that and then I I don't
want to leave without asking about
quantitative tightening anything either
yeah actually I was going to ask about
um bonus cap so this is uh well not
monitor committee but obviously
yeah
as the as the the all round top
ranking supervisor
um all right so the one of the survivals
of the uh list trust Premiership is the
uh commitment by the government to scrap
the uh so-called bonus cap
um and that was supposedly introduced
obviously the UK government at the time
didn't support it but that was
supposedly introduced to stop uh
excessive risk-taking in the bank
industry do you have any concerns about
getting rid of it in terms of encourage
that will lead to more results I mean I
I'm ancient enough to have appeared
before this committee about a decade ago
on this so when you're a chief executive
of the pra what else briefly at the FSA
and said that I didn't agree with the
bonus cat when it was being uh
introduced as part of European EU
legislation
and one of the things I remember science
sorry that this sounds so repressing
don't mean I don't want to sound like
that but I was concerned that it would
lead to two things one is that it would
lead to an increase in permanent pay a
substitution from uh from Bonus to
permanent plan two that it really it
didn't have the right uh incentives in
terms of risk-taking
um I think the first of those and we've
published evidence to suggest that first
of those actually has happened
um on on the question of you know why
why do we support getting rid of it
um well first of all it does it doesn't
have the right incentives it has led to
that secondly as you know I think we you
know we've we've always had a UK uh you
know you know frame of policy framework
in place which remains in place which
has a different uh sort of thrust to us
and I think is consistent with the right
incentives which is that it involves
well several things but one is deferring
deferral of the payment out of the of
course good proportion of the variable
remuneration and the potential then for
what's called malice although I often
get transcripts back saying it's malice
and we don't have a policy of malice I
would say but but malice which is taking
it back before it's actually given out
as it were and clawback even which of
course goes beyond that point the other
thing is that we have a policy of saying
that we want uh you know a large part of
the variable remuneration paid in
instruments which are then subsequently
you know reflect risk uh not cash in
other words
um so we think you know our view is that
we've got a better policy framework in
place and the bonus cap has the wrong
the wrong incentives attached to it so
getting rid of it won't lead to more
risky no we don't know and that's what I
mean I felt when when obviously it was
advocated by the government I mean my
view was look we're technology
consistent line on this
um so you know it's like the obvious
very clear on it
yeah the what another big or another
change that's happening is the to the
ring fencing regime uh and uh after the
ski Opera review is recommended various
um uh reforms to it and we did do it
um have some questions here the bank
CEOs uh earlier this week wasn't it just
a couple days ago
um do you have any
concerns about the changes to the ring
fencing regime do you think uh there's
anything no I think the the proposals
that Keith skyken his uh his group
proposed are sensible and you know I
think my whole approach only sort of
areas of policy is that they don't
remain you know they shouldn't remain
fixed real time actually they'll become
you know dangerously not sort of not
consistent if they do
so I think the things that Keith has
proposed are sensible
um I I would also say I know there's
been some debate about the relationship
between the ring France regime and the
REM and the um resolution regime yeah
I see them as compliments they're not
substitute they're compliments
right so the the fact that we've now got
a better recovery regime we don't
totally no hard work in you know in a
real process but that's not an argument
for getting rid of no no I think ring
fencing makes the x or would make the
execution of a resolution and Recovery
more straightforward in that sense my
final question on the uh as the
Prudential regulator uh is on the Basel
3.1 measures uh which uh uh I think
being consulted on at the moment that
will increase the capital requirements
for uh lending to smes and UK companies
with no formal credit rating and
infrastructure projects and obviously
under the EU when the EU came through
this originally they effectively reduced
the risk waiting for smes
um presumably this would push up the
cost of I mean it's inevitable it will
pushover cost of lending to smes and to
infrastructure projects is that is that
desirable we are
one thing and then a bit of History we
are we are in a consultation so we want
evidence and we've asked the banks to
provide us with their evidence of what
the measures would do in that sense
versus the current things so I think
they asked that question and I you know
I can speak for some words I'm sure we
will be very happy to come to committee
and and lay out that evidence and put it
put it right to you and put it before
you because it's important just a bit of
History so
in the earlier implementation in the
Basel free implementation the EU did not
Implement Basel
yep properly and has been judged by the
Basel committee to be non-compliant
because the UK is a member of the EU at
that point so we had to implement the EU
rules
now Basel 3.1 amends the SME and
infrastructure regimes to reduce the
capital requirements
by the way actually that's most is you
know applying to the standardized
approach obviously if you're on IRB
that's a different performance for the
big Banks it's a different story anyway
3.1 reduces it so our proposal in the
consultation is to implement those
reduced Basel numbers the EU as I say
did a did a special thing on Basel 3.0
and in and you know we think they intend
to continue those and not Implement
Basel there's a you probably read
there's quite a dispute now between the
regulators and the
we thought is when the EU on this
question but the key thing is that in
the consultation is we want the evidence
of you know how these these regimes
compare and then we'll be able to assess
that and we'll be completely transparent
about that to you happy to do that
okay
Danny yeah great thanks uh just we've
discussed earlier the supply side and
the inability of interest rate changes
to significantly uh affect all needs to
affect uh some precise changes there but
but it would be very interested in your
general view whichever if you want to
jump in on this on on the challenge that
the UK faces we have this chronic
productivity problem in this country
we've never recovered from 2008. and uh
in the absence of any labor colleagues
here I thought I might ask a slightly
political question to you uh
it was interested in reports that this
reshuffle we've just had and the moving
around of ministerial departments that
the um the Prime Minister initially
offered the science department Michael
gave I'm not asking you to offer comment
on that uh I don't even know if it's
true when I was shot by was the
suggestion that the science department
should we see it was a senior new
Department of State so they're leveling
up Department
and the implication that what the UK
needs most is you know a revolution in
Science and Tech rather than leveling up
agenda I'd just be interested in your
views without getting into the policies
of that please don't
feel drawn but but in terms of
challenging the UK's productivity
challenge would you prioritize
you know investment policy political
support
into r d technology science all into the
rebalancing of the UK economy to make
sure all the regions of the country are
growing well and how would you
distinguish between those problems lucky
enough to have a real experts on the
subject it's not me it's Jonathan so I
don't mind I'll let Jonathan come in
first it's very kind of very frightening
uh of things on this if I may so thank
thanks for the question one is
I've always thought one of the good
features of the UK is that actually
science policy has been remarkably
stable and I can be very non-political
about this because I think credit should
be given to David sainsbury who was on
the labor side and David Willits on the
conservative side the two of them I
think ensured that a lot of science
policy was kind of taken away from the
politics of all of this so so I I think
that's you know a good part of that and
we certainly have lots and lots of
academic evidence and practical evidence
that the the benefits of having a strong
University sector and a strong research
base flow quickly well not maybe not
quickly but they certainly flow over to
the private sector as well in terms of
boosting productivity so that's one set
of remarks second set of remarks is I I
guess the priority would be around
investment so again if I can take us
back to the report in chart 3.7 on page
87 you'll have seen that we've got a
diagram there about investment in the UK
this is business investment I should say
lots of different measures of all that
essentially business investment was sort
of steaming along up until 2016 and
unfortunately it's more or less
flatlined um since then so uh the the
one if I had to sort of boil it or boil
a complicated issue down to one thing uh
it would be encouraging those types of
investment would be but you're not
particularly interested in where they go
you have a spatially blind attitude to
business investment do you use wherever
the greatest returns can be realized
rather than thinking about investment in
places other than Cambridge which is uh
so the the normal Cambridge the issue
with investment is the the investment
which is going to give us the biggest
bang for our buck in terms of
productivity is probably intangible
investment that is to say r d and design
and software and all of those kind of
issues and intangible investment does
the best job when it's in a cluster with
other like corporations who are also
making intangible Investments because
the r d scientists can get together with
other scientists the software writers
can get together with the movie makers
to make the you know CGI stuff and and
all those kinds of things so I think
inevitably be given the cluster benefits
from that type of investment then the
benefits of that in terms of sort of the
immediate kind of overall will be
concentrated in towns and cities which
takes us then to issues around planning
when we sort of worry about policy now
of course once we have this investment
and the cake gets bigger back to the
earlier discussion then Society can
choose as they wish to distribute the
cake you know around to which ever
parties they want to distribute us and
as you were saying earlier on that's not
a question for us that's a question uh
for you it's a distribution do you mean
through what through through welfare oh
yeah through the topic systems through
welfare or public services or or
whatever I mean that feels like the old
model which is that the southeast
generates income for the treasury which
then hands out as sort of compensation
to the places which weren't involved in
the production of values I'm not I'm not
saying that that's right or wrong I'm
just saying that because of the
characteristics of this rather powerful
form of investment because they as I say
that they they get their most bang for
about when they're clustered together
yeah I think inevitably those benefits
are going to be generated that are quite
geographically okay but do you think
there's a role for government in in
creating or encouraging clusters in new
places that not not the traditional
centers of of development and growth and
how effective do you think it would be
for government to say we're going to
we're going to create a new sector
cluster in a place which hasn't had one
traditionally well I think that's true
and Andrew's looking at me because this
is not really monetary policy
I I I'm off uh narrow brief but if I can
just offer a view
um I think there is some benefit in that
but I think what the what we know about
cluster policy is it takes a very long
time so Stanford University for example
is an amazing cluster out in Silicon
Valley but you know 100 years ago
Stanford was referred to Stanford
University was referred to as the farm
nobody went there and it was almost an
unknown kind of University so these
things take a long time to bear fruit
okay well well thank you can I just just
to finish for Me Maybe one for the
governor and this does range rather
broadly Beyond uh monthly policy but
it's related
and you might want to comment on on
brexit in this context if you like which
is just and I noticed hearteningly uh
that do you think that although there
have been undoubted impacts from brexit
in terms of obviously political
distraction uh and significant
uncertainty for business the uh I think
the reduced Divergence was the phrase uh
from uh in terms of uh growth with trade
with EU versus trade with non-eu
countries so maybe things are looking up
if you would like to uh comment I'd be
delighted or maybe that you can uh
conclude that the effects of brexit as
you might put it transitory uh so any
any thoughts on that but I I really want
to hear from you on the overall model
that in my view was rejected by the
brexit votes and by the majority of the
country versus optimization just now for
20 years we've had an economic model
dependent on cheap credit printing money
uh from the bank cheap labor from
immigration High immigration policy and
cheap Imports due to our strong pound
and all of that in a sense has had some
benefits to some people but for the
majority of working people in this
country it has not been helpful and as a
result they vote to change that model
not just to leave the EU it was more
wholesale
rejection of the economic model that
we've had for so long do you accept that
your mission as part of economic
policymakers in this country is to help
make that decision successful and to
make therefore to make brexit work and
how are you doing that
well let me say two things to start with
I've said this many times before as a
public official and servant I'm neutral
per se on the issue second thing to say
is set as many times will as you rightly
say It was decided by the people in a
referendum
it's our job to implement and and and
where it affects us to yeah to to to
implement uh
the policies that follow from it and
that goes back to the discussion where
we're just having a financial regulation
actually so yeah we are yeah we're clear
on that I mean that's that's very
important on this question I mean you
raised about uh trade
I think our staff have done a lot of
work with ons and hmrc on the trade data
because it's been though it's been very
hard to interpret some of the trade data
um because there's been a shift in the
method of collection
the conclusion of that work is that the
fact of brexit on trade which we have
said for some time we thought would be
initially negative
has come through possibly more quickly
than thought it was doesn't mean so
it'll be bigger
just means it comes seems to have come
through more quickly
as you write said that we've you know
again we've said for a long time there
will of course be a over the longer term
an adjustment to the real economy to
that the the economy will adjust that's
that's natural it will be supported no
doubt by public policy to do so
so in the initial phase we think it's
probably come through rather more
quickly based on you know the work the
work has staff have done on trade data
uh so far that's that's the only
conclusion we have and we've we've
factored that into the into the into the
monetary policy assessment because yeah
we do believe there's a relationship
between openness and productivity
so that productivity that that shock to
productivity that we've had in our
assumptions for some time now hasn't
increased but it has come through
probably more quickly okay thank you
Professor uh yeah so our role in the
economy is framed by the remit so we
need to get inflation to two percent
that's that's our contribution to the
economy and the MPC has a track record
of having achieved that two percent
inflation over its um 25 years as we
said before we've been shocked by
um unprecedented shocks covet the war in
Ukraine and so on and the role of the
MPC in that setting is to return
inflation to Target sustainably
and that's our part we cannot affect the
productive side the supply side of the
economy that's um that's from government
to do our role is to stick to the two
percent Target in the medium term
okay thank you very much thanks thank
you Danny and I just want to conclude
with the subject of quantitative
tightening and quantitative easing
because uh as you know we've launched an
inquiry into that last week and uh it
was striking I thought that in this
monetary policy report you mentioned
simply that they exist as tools you
didn't really say anything more about
them uh and I just wondered if you did
at all discuss them in the meeting
itself well our normal practice is to
comment on that in the minutes of the
meetings actually where we do get
obviously reports from the staff on the
operations that have been done where
it's got to we you know we set a target
for quantitative tightening over a year
so we're not going to vary that Target
so we're not at a point when we
obviously the committee will have to
reconsider that when we get to that
point but we're not at that point at the
moment so the operation the operations
yeah to the extent we cover them it's in
the minutes
now we've been
um conducting those operations now since
November
um and so far I would say you know
they've been you know very very smooth
in that sense when you're 8 27 at the
moment is that Rising Yes
somewhere between 8 25 and 8 27. okay
and then the 19.3 billion that you
bought uh yes to stabilize the markets
uh because of the liability driven
investment uh crisis uh which is
obviously separate those have now all
been they've all been sold yes and have
you found as a result of being able to
sell those I think it sounds like
relatively easily uh has that informed
uh what the operational team are doing
in terms of the quantitative tightening
at the moment
it it has
um we sold the 19 uh it was over 19
using a different
um approach actually which was in the
quantity of tightening guilt operations
we do auctions and we name the amount we
we did the uh the 19 plus on a basis
what we call an open book approach where
we set the price and said you know what
do you want
um and actually we sold it very quickly
actually and we started towards the end
of November and we're done mid-January
12th of January I think was the last one
now I what I would say is this it it
hasn't it hasn't changed our view on how
we do the guilt process uh auctions
process we've set the objective of 80
billion pounds of reduction and that's
both through the active sales and the
runoff for the first year and we will
stick to that because it's operating
smoothly it's not
disrupting markets indeed up with so
markets are now here more stable than
they were
a few months ago but we will then review
it now it is we have we have got a
second set of sales going on we're
selling we're gradually signing off the
uh corporate bond portfolio that's 20
billion uh and we have taken over some
of the some of the lessons from the 19
billion sale process into that sale
process as well you've sold all the
corporates no no it's all gone yet no no
no no out of the 20 out of 20. I think
we're about 40 45 of the way through at
the moment okay and then plus there's
the 80 on top of that and then there's
the 19.3 that you've already done uh and
uh in terms of how that uh experience
now of some quantitative tightening you
know one of the great unknowns in terms
of quantitative what it equates to in
terms of a monetary tightening amongst
you policy tightening are we any more
informed on that at this point
oh he might want to come on this I don't
think we have
um I mean we don't have enough
systematic evidence uh yet
it's a bit early for that frankly what
we can what we can observe I'll just
finish off is obviously Market reactions
to it we are not seeing any uh what I
call Market disturbance uh yeah we look
at the conditions in markets around the
auctions we look at measures of
liquidity so bid our spreads have come
down for instance during this period
quite a bit
I mean just I don't have much to add on
that uh I mean I think there has been
emphasis in what Andrew has described
and maybe in the way you phrase the
questions on if you like the operational
aspects of this
um I think from a monetary policy point
of view it is a more slow-moving
business
we anticipated that because effectively
and reflecting the fact this is not at
the front and center the discussion in
the monetary policy report
that quantitative tightening would if
you like run a little in the background
on this lower frequency year-to-year
basis not be so much in the
month-to-month meeting to meeting basis
where we would focus on using bank rate
as the active instrument and of course
now Bank graders moved to a level where
we have scope to move it in either
direction which is being part of the
discussion this morning so that if you
like validates this in the background
approach I think there are different
views on the committee so I should
recognize that my personal view is I
would expect the sale of these bonds to
have some effect on market pricing along
the yield curve I think that is very
difficult to quantify
um and of course there are lots of other
things influencing the market yield
curve and I think that should not be a
concern for the conduct of monetary
policy focusing on the use of bank rate
as the active instrument because as is
the case with all our decisions we
condition our monetary policy stance on
developments of all aspects of the
economy including asset prices including
the station of the yield curve so that's
the sense in which although it's an
interesting kind of academic question
how has quantitative tightening affected
the yield curve from our point of view
because we observe the yield curve we
can still set monetary policy using bank
rate
Hugh you mentioned that transmission
mechanism there's also the fact that the
quantitative easing it used to be a
profitable exercise for the treasury and
used to hand back the profits and now
you're projecting that there are going
to be losses and that the treasury is
going to have to absorb those
um so that's another way in which
presumably there could be some
tightening experience through this
change in Direction
what I'd say to that is I mean what has
happened in terms of the cash flows is
not a surprise
it was always envisaged that there would
be a point at which those cash flows
would turn negative
and it's really I think a fiscal
decision which is a decision more for
the treasury than for us to work out how
to incorporate that in their own fiscal
plastic planning of which this is one
part so it I would say this probably
isn't a monetary policy implication of
all these things but it would be on the
fiscal side but it does tighten fiscal
policy which might have a monetary
implication
um I would be cautious about saying that
because of course I mean
through time we have transferred a lot
of money to the treasury all the coupons
that we received
um on the bonds that were held uh have
already been given to the treasury so
what the treasury did with them maybe
they pay down debt maybe they spent them
these are things that it's not for me to
comment on that was a fiscal decision
and of course
um just as it wasn't for me to comment
on on that side of the operation I was
not at the bank at the time but I
wouldn't have commented on them anyway
it's not really for us to comment on the
other side so that is I think a fiscal
question it's about 100 it's 123.8
billion pounds that we transferred over
in cash flow it is yeah and uh how does
your approach differ Governor to the
approach taken by the FED now that
they've reached the same information
point and European Central well the
difference with the FED is that the FED
has a much shorter duration book of
assets and the main reason for that is
because the U.S government debt has a
much shorter average duration UK
government downtown has a longer average
duration than many other countries so
many resources is a good thing actually
and and the bank's decision right at the
outset of quantities and going back to
2009 was that we would be neutral in
terms of Market impact and so
essentially the bought and three buckets
short medium long really to replicate
the the stock of the stock of guilts and
in issue
um what that means is that because we've
got a longer average duration on the
book
um if we were to rely on the approach
the FED can take which is is just is
passive run officer there yeah it
happens very quickly
obviously the process would take a much
longer time
um and that's really what has led us to
therefore to conduct active sales uh
which is different from certainly the
the fence approach if I can make one
more point it just it might be useful
just I was happy to come back in your in
the inquiry which by the way I think is
I'm very much welcome the fact that
you're doing this I think it's important
to you know keep this keep this under
review
in terms of the total stock of
assistance that we apply we we provide
and 825 is a as you said is not a bad
way of looking at it
we will not take it down to zero because
we can't because there's a demand
there's an equilibrium demand for
reserves in the in in the banking system
um because reserves are the if you see
at the other side of the balance sheet
um now we don't know what that
equilibrium level is because
um all I can I can tell you two things
one is the number we have at the moment
is higher than it is and the number we
had before the financial crisis was way
too low
you know it will settle at some points
um we will then have to decide
um what the rights in a sense mix of
short-term repos and outright Holdings
is to match that so we will have a
decision to take and you know the
treasury will have to be part of that
decision but I just want to caution that
the idea will sell from 825 to zero
that's not yeah yeah and then what I've
been adjustment done at that point but
I'd just bear that in mind no and then
we we obviously will take more evidence
on this because this is uh going to be a
topic of of interest to The Wider
committee but I think at this point
um I am just going to thank you for your
time I think that it has been uh
extremely interesting to explore the
thinking behind where we are
um the role of hindsight versus
contemporary evidence that the word of
the risks to the upside on inflation and
you know just speaking personally at the
end of the session I still think the
factors that led to an upside surprise
on inflation are potentially still with
us in terms of the secondary effects in
the economy and I know that you note
that in your monetary policy report
inflation is the worst
tax that we can inflict on the economy
and it hurts the poorest the most and
therefore I just would conclude by
urging you to remain extremely Vigilant
about those becoming more embedded in
the UK economy
and so thank you very much for your time
order order I declare this session over
thank you thank you very much indeed
thank you very much